-Whenever Donald Trump
holds a press conference,
his rambling,
nonsensical answers
raise more questions
than they answer.
So we decided to hold anothe
one right here, right now.
That's right, Donald Trump
and the "Late Night" press corps
are here in studio
and ready to go.
So without further ado,
it's time for the "Late Night"
White House press conference
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, Mr. President.
Mr. President, over here.
Mr. President.
Yes, Mr. President,
you walked by the podium.
Mr. President. Thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
President Trump...
Oh, I just realized
I forgot my pen.
Can I borrow yours?
-They all want the pen.
Can you believe these people
Should I give it to him?
-Hey! Nice throw.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, you got quite an arm
On to my questions.
The Mueller Report
claimed that you fired
former FBI Director James Come
to try and stop
the Russia investigation.
Why were you so scared of him?
-He's so big.
-I heard they bought you
a treadmill to use
when you moved into
The White House.
How has that been working out?
-It's never been used,
brand-new.
-How many porn stars
have you slept with?
-More than any other
president except one.
-Oh, except one?
Well, which one?
-You know who the one is?
Take a guess.
George Washington.
-You're saying that
George Washington
slept with more
porn stars than you?
-Can you believe that?
Boy, oh, boy.
-Yeah. What does Melania say
when you tell her you love her
-Thank you.
-Mr. President, when you hav
championship teams
at The White House, you tend t
serve them fast food.
Where do all the
leftover burgers go?
-Back to me in the Oval Office
where I will dispose of it
-What did you think about
the new "Avengers" movie?
-Went on so long,
and there wasn't a thing
could you do about it.
-What's Mike Pence's
biggest fear?
-A back-door attack.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How would you describe
your tweets?
-Early warning signs of
mental illness.
-Can I ask a question?
How do they cut your hair?
-With a knife,
viciously and violently.
-At the end of the day,
what does it say on your Fitbit?
-That's step one.
-I know one thing you and
have in common --
we love our Disney movies.
Mr. President, what gives Dumb
the ability to fly?
-It is the spirit that lives i
each and every one of you.
-That was really beautiful
What did your physician say when
he squeezed your belly?
-This is surplus. This is extra.
We don't need it.
-Is it true that your son, Eric,
picks his nose and saves all
his boogers in a jar?
-He named every one of them.
-What happens when
you're on a see-saw?
-It's not going anywhere.
-What did you say when
you found out
you had erectile dysfunction
-Happy birthday, Melania.
-Let's have a little bit of fun.
I've got a riddle for you, okay?
Why did the pony
take a throat lozenge?
-Why?
-Because he was a little horse
You know...a little horse.
-Nobody gets it. I don't get it.
-You know, a pony is
a little horse,
and your throat can be hoarse.
So, we're almost out of time
so I'd like to finish
with a question I always ask
How's your penis?
-It's in bad shape,
but it's structurally sound.
-Well, looks like we're
out of time.